the people who invite me I work since 8
morning 7 p.m. in the hospital I put the
for okay I have 8 years old waiting for
me you and you ask me to kick out it's
very disrespectful I mean if you knew
all that you could have just followed
the rules though we because she wanted
you over and over again to stop over
talking and even while you were doing it
just now she still told you okay stop
stop stop Bo you just didn't y y'all see
how y'all see
how see how her emotions just took over
though right it's just a clear example
of how everything she was saying was
[__] she doesn't like
it put a l of time and effort to you all
right it's a clear it's a clear example
can you take her out please thank you